jours à vous merci d'être avec nous en
ligne en direct sur arte france je le
disais près de 38 millions d'américains
qui ont pointé au chômage d'abord un
commentaire sur ce chiffre historique
depuis la grande dépression
oui effectivement lié à trois mois je
rappelle à nos auditeurs que le taux de
chômage aux etats unis se situer à 1 3
nuls 5 % et aujourd'hui d'après les
meilleures estimations on va finir avec
un taux de chômage qui se situe entre 15
et 20% et tout cela dans un délai de
deux mois et demi soit de trois mois
c'est effectivement un cataclysme
économique qu'aucun membre de toutes les
générations depuis 10 ans n'a jamais
connu
est ce qu'à votre avis ce chiffre il
peut être réversible assez rapidement
baj alors la grande différence entre les
systèmes économiques américains et
français et qu'il y à beaucoup plus de
souplesse concernant le marché du
travail aux etats unis
donc d'un côté il est beaucoup plus
facile de licencier les gens mais d'un
autre côté
théoriquement le marché de travail et
plus souple et il ya impossibilité plus
rapide que certaines américain de
retrouver du travail
le système le système d'indemnités
aimant généreux aux états unis qu'en
france la situation elle est très
compliqué donc pour les américains qui
perdent leur emploi alors justement les
américains regardent vers l'europe
notamment la france le système du
chômage partiel en se posant la question
pourquoi une telle régis n'existe pas
aux états unis alors un pas vers le
système le système européen commun été
fait par le président 30 en envoyant et
par le shaq de 1200 dollars à certains
américains et entonnant des traits et
des subventions à d'autres entreprises
donc c'est par le système européen et on
essaie on a compris aux états unis qu'il
est plus facile de matinée les salariés
en activité plutôt que de les licencier
et de les reprendre
une fois que la reprise comme
un mot sur le système de couverture de
santé c'est souvent lié à l'emploi aux
états unis ça veut dire que pertes
d'emplois c'est synonyme de pertes de
couverture sociale
effectivement c'est une double
catastrophe d'une part l'assurance santé
et d'autre part un système de soins
médicaux aux états unis en de prix on a
quasi majorité de la population
donc les gens vont se trouver à la fois
des muni d'un job et du protection de
santé j'ai quatre strophes humaines au
même titre que économique et donald
trump lui il est pressé il veut des
consignes et à tout prix est ce que
c'est la solution justement pour lutter
contre cette ce chômage et cette crise
économique
alors je rappelle utilement de huttes et
du novembre on aura des élections
présidentielles aux états unis il y a
trois mois et grâce notamment aux
performances économiques
il y avait les gens même les gens qui la
met tant qu'ils pensaient que 30 était
presque garantie d'être réélu
aujourd'hui avec un taux de chômage
entre 15 et 20% et une remise en cause
de sa gestion de cette crise sanitaire
veilleux des mois c'est justement sur
les mesures qu'il a prises pour faire
face à la crise
aujourd'hui est-ce que lui finalement il
peut tirer son épingle du jeu au final
on pas votre avis il y avait tous les
états unis comme il ya deux écoles de
france et en europe il ya une école qui
dit il faut redémarrer l'économie a vite
quitte à prendre un risque sanitaire
supplémentaires il y à l'autre école qui
dit qu'il faut que tous restent fermés
au moins dans les zones les plus
impactés 1 le temps de contrôler la
pompe est dit très clairement du tram et
côté c'est à dire quoi qu'il arrive ils
vont redémarrer d'économie américain
d'une part parce que ça va aider deux
pays et d'autre part peut-être plus
important pour lui ça avait des gens n'a
aidé notamment ses chances d'être réélu
en novembre
merci beaucoup avoue christophe arméno
je rappelle que vous êtes avocat au
barreau de paris
et de new york à merci